all right wash trading
members of the house of representatives
have now proposed a bill uh from monday
that imposes wash sale rules on
commodities currencies and digital
assets here is what a wash sale is if i
buy let's say a stock at a hundred
dollars and that stock falls 30 now it's
at 70 bucks and i sell the stock
and then i wait 10 seconds and then i
buy back the stock
technically i should be able to book a
30
loss i lost 30
i bought something and i sold it when it
went down uh 30 i booked a 30 loss now
historically what people tried to do was
they just bought the stock right back
because what that would allow them to do
is they still have let's say it was one
share of amazon hundred dollars it falls
to 70. i sell it i book a 30 loss and i
still have the one share of amazon
because i bought it right back so i hold
one share of amazon but i just booked a
30 loss i can put that against my income
or on capital gains later uh in the year
obviously there's people who say you
shouldn't be able to do that in the
stock market so there was a rule passed
the wash sale rule which says if you go
and you actually sell the asset at a
loss you cannot buy it back within i
believe it's 90 days i'm sorry uh within
30 days and if you buy it back within
the 30 day period then you cannot book
the loss so if i bought it at 100 one
share of amazon falls to 70 and i sell
it i can book the 30 loss but if i buy
back amazon with that money before the
end of 30 days then i cannot take the
loss so what historically people now are
doing in the stock market is they are
saying okay you know what i'm going to
do i'm going to buy amazon and when
amazon falls 30 i'm going to sell it at
70 bucks i'm going to take my 30 loss
because during the 30 days i'm not just
going to sit in cash know what i'm going
to do i'm going to buy another stock
that has a very high correlation to
amazon maybe i'll go and i'll buy
shopify or i'll buy another stock that
gives me exposure to a similar industry
or a similar type of correlation and
therefore i didn't buy back amazon so i
still get my 30 loss but i'm holding a
stock now that has high correlation to
amazon so i still get some of the
exposure to that asset so there are
obviously strategies that people are
employing in order to have a tax
advantage account
wash trading is a attempt at tax lost
harvesting tax loss harvesting is simply
the idea that if you're holding an asset
and it is dropped a lot in value and you
sell it you can book that loss now
in crypto
commodities and also in currencies wash
trading rules do not apply so what a lot
of people have been doing in the
commodities market and currencies and
also in bitcoin or other
cryptocurrencies is the following i buy
the asset at 100 it drops to 70. i sell
it i book my 30 loss and i buy it right
back seconds later i still have the same
amount of the asset and now i have a 30
loss and i do this over and over and
over and over again and i end up
stacking up a very large
negative tax bill because what i have is
i have a bunch of losses on the year so
in theory
you could watch let's say in 2017
bitcoin go from 1 000 to 20 000 in 2017
but there was five or six 30 percent
drawdowns if you had a sophisticated way
of executing this strategy you could
have actually still held your one
bitcoin that you bought for a thousand
dollars when it was at twenty thousand
and you could sell it at twenty thousand
and pay no taxes because along the way
you would have picked up twenty thousand
dollars of tax lost harvesting so you
would have taken the twenty thousand
dollars worth of losses and it would
have put it against the 20 000 of gains
and therefore it would be nullified and
you would have made 20 000 and not had a
tax bill
the house members don't like that idea
so they proposed a bill that would
impose these wash sale rules on
commodities currencies and digital
assets and so the idea is that if we
have this quote here uh from uh ivory
johnson the founder of delancey wealth
management he says the similarities
start and end with the coins being
exchanged on a blockchain using that
logic stocks traded on an exchange new
york stock exchange or otherwise are not
considered one in the same either stated
plainly bitcoin is to ether what gold is
to visa they're not substantially
similar and should not in my opinion
trigger the wash sale rule so there is a
conversation happening right now about
could the wash sale rules apply if
somebody had bitcoin at 100 i dropped
the 70 i sell it and then i take the 70
and i go and i buy ether does that
not should that not be allowed for me to
book the loss because i actually bought
back
the same asset
i don't know
right my get is obviously unbiased but
like no
it's like saying as he's saying here if
you sell amazon and then you buy back
you know whatever uh uh walmart they're
two different stocks
so the wash sale rules don't apply in
that situation why would they apply here
on the cryptocurrency but if you buy the
same asset you do believe like if you if
bitcoin was at 100 it went to 70 you
booked that 30 loss and you re-bought
bitcoin at the 70 when you sold it
you don't you don't think that should
trigger the wash sale rule i think i
think this bill is this this rule is
gonna get passed crypto's gonna change
it's gonna be more regulated in that
aspect of it um and enjoy it while you
can
i don't know if the law is gonna get
passed or not but i think if one if it
does not get passed
my guess is that because the commodities
and currency uh players have a lot of
lobbying power in this i was going to
say it's not just crypto yeah yeah the
crypto industry if it was just crypto i
think it would have a higher percent
chance of passing because of the
narrative in washington because of the
lack of uh kind of lobbying power but
the commodity and currency people are
gonna be like hey listen
[Music]
you're not gonna ruin this good thing we
got going
right uh it is my guess what do you
think joe well they're also doing it to
try to raise money for a 3.5 trillion
dollar spending package so ooh don't
don't talk about the spending don't be
logical
we don't want to talk about spending i
mean let's be clear why they're trying
to do this it's not to uh protect retail
traders or any other stuff that they'll
claim it's to raise money 3.5 trillion
dollars for spending and so when you
think of this should they treat
physical currencies different than
cryptocurrencies like if they pass it
for physical currency it should apply to
digital currencies and vice versa if
they pass it for digital currencies
should it apply to physical just the
wall shale in general yeah yeah just
just watch sale
yeah i mean i don't think it's uh
it's necessarily
it's pretty clear right like you could
there's some nuance to it but when it
comes to uh currencies or stocks or
bonds or whatever it is the wash sale
rule is uh pretty cut and dry right like
it's to avoid uh people capitalizing and
buying the same asset back to help with
their tax tax rates right and i think uh
within the crypto space people have done
it historically because it's been
allowed and if you were to take that
away they would find out uh they would
find uh whether it's unique ways to get
around it or whatnot
but this has been a thing that's been
happening in stocks and other markets
for a long time so i don't necessarily
know if you can just say hey look it's
happening in other currency so we should
do it in crypto i think you have to look
at each market specifically and how the
dynamics impact it uh but if it gets
passed for
other currencies uh and commodities
it'll get passed for crypto also for
sure um
one last thing i want to say about this
is we have this chart that basically
shows uh how wash
sales work
and uh
anytime you got to pull this up to
figure out taxes it's like basically
just as complex as the tax code itself
uh and so uh what this essentially shows
here is you buy a hundred shares of this
stock it costs two thousand dollars you
then sell the hundred shares it costs
1200 so you have an 800 loss uh if you
buy the 100 shares uh right back at a
cost of 1300 bucks you then get the
sale
but
the sale is uh you can't book the loss
right because you basically bought back
in 30 days
but
if you sold it on
by the way for one isn't that uh april
fool's
if you sold it on april fool's and then
you buy it back july first yeah
big brain attention to detail if uh if
you buy back on july 1st then uh it
would not fall under the wash sale and
you would be fine to book your loss so
pretty incredible to see uh how much but
your cost basis wouldn't wouldn't change
just on your taxes right exactly hey all
i'm saying is this rule does not
currently exist in uh in crypto so you
should take advantage of it if you have
the opportunity what's up guys bang bang
thanks so much for watching the best
business show today if we're gonna be
the best business show we obviously need
the best partner that's why the
exclusive sponsor the best business show
is sofi they're an all-in-one platform
that allows you to invest in all kinds
of different assets including stocks
etfs crypto ipos and they even have an
automated investing function if that's
your thing so before we start getting
after it again make sure that you go
download sofi you get an invest account
and when you make your first crypto
trade regardless of what you buy they'll
give you 10 in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]